für nix nachgefragt an diesem morgen mit
johannes leithäuser von der frankfurter
allgemeinen zeitung herr leithäuser ihr
eindruck zum trio fangen wir doch mal so
an
hallo ich muss sagen ich fand es
eigentlich eher ein bisschen langweilig
denn von allen dreien kam eine ganze
zeit lang bekannte positionen die
natürlich auch alle abgefragt wurden
also wir wissen glaube ich hinlänglich
welche einstellung zu corona und
klimaschutz
unter den kandidaten herrscht es wurde
erst gegen ende etwas spannender als
themen aufgerufen wurden die wir bisher
nicht so sehr im wahlkampf behandelt
haben beispielsweise zukunft der
rentenversicherung beispielsweise
gesundheitssystem aber viele fragen die
uns in den nächsten jahren sehr
beschäftigen werden etwa außenpolitik
oder auch was wird wie wird die alternde
gesellschaft
mit schrumpfenden erwerbstätigenzahlen
und anderen fertig werden die bleiben
doch eher am rande
nun hat die cdu reklamiert dass jetzt
die aufholjagd begonnen habe so haben
sie das auch so gesehen
naja ich glaube dass tatsächlich arm
ihrer schätze ich so gut geschlagen hat
wie er konnte aber das ganze setting in
dem dieses trio stattfand es ja auch ein
stück weit irreführend es wird so getan
als werden wir würde einer der dreien
die da steht am ende quasi eine
kanzlermehrheit um sich versammeln und
wenn die zuschauer dann olaf scholz mit
40 prozent bewerten ist dass eine zahl
die natürlich von den umfragen für seine
partei nicht gedeckt wird die bei 25
prozent liegt und so wie es aussieht
wird der nächste bundeskanzler im
bundestag mit einer kanzlermehrheit von
mindestens drei parteien gewählt werden
müssen und das heißt alles das was die
kandidaten der vortragen wird in einem
koalitionsvereinbarung man sagen wir mal
durch drei geteilt werden insofern sind
die positionen die jetzt vorgestellt
werden auch im wenn eine neue regierung
gebildet sein wird nur noch zum teil
valide
bleiben wir mal bei diesen fragen diese
blitzumfragen von gestern sind ja nicht
ganz repräsentativ aber was wir so haben
sind die umfragen aus den letzten die
letzten umfragen die es gegeben hat die
repräsentative da liegt die spd bei
ungefähr 25 prozent die cdu bei ungefähr
20 21 22 prozent glauben sie dass das
nicht das wäre ja die führung einer wie
auch immer gearteten koalition sich noch
ändern kann
das glaube ich schon also ich würde
sagen solange die zahl derer die auch
gemessen wird ja manchmal aber nicht so
oft genannt wird der die noch nicht
entschieden sind und die nach den
angaben durch gestern gehört habe bei
mehr als einem drittel liegt also bei
über 33 prozent solange die noch größer
ist halt die zahl der führenden partei
kann sich natürlich noch vieles ändern
die cdu hat ja so ein bisschen
lagerwahlkampf versuch zu betreiben das
kam gestern nicht so ganz raus aber auf
den wahlkampfveranstaltungen sieht man
dass sie schüren so zu sagen wenn man es
so nennen darf die angst vor einer
rot-rot-grünen regierung ist das was was
ihrer meinung nach verfängt
ich glaube tatsächlich der cdu geht es
zum momentan wirklich wie sie sagen
darum die eigenen anhänger zu
mobilisieren und dafür ist das
vielleicht ein taugliches mittel
darüber hinaus glaube ich ist es auch
irgendwie ein rückwärtsgewandter reflex
denn wenn es tatsächlich so sein wird
dass nach dem wahltag eine regierung nur
gebildet werden kann mit drei parteien
und das jeweils zwei den
unterschiedlichen lagern angehören dann
braucht man also eine dritte die zum
anderen lager gehört und da hört denn
spätestens das lagerdenken auf also
entweder müssen union und fdp die grünen
überzeugen oder spd und grüne müssen die
fdp überzeugen und beides wird glaube
ich nach diesem wahltag ein schwieriges
geschäft werden und wir werden da noch
lange zu sehen und hoffentlich
irgendwann zu einem ergebnis kommen
wir zum schluss vielleicht gern noch mal
zu annalena baerbock kommen da liegen
die umfragen für die grünen und bei um
die 15 prozent dh sie wird
wahrscheinlich nicht die nächste
kanzlerin sein das kann man doch jetzt
schon relativ sicher sagen oder lehne
ich mich dazu weit aus dem fenster
also nach dem überraschenden wechsel in
den umfragewerten die von den
verschiedenen umfragen
veröffentlicht werden wäre ich mir in
diesem wahlkampf mit nichts besonders
sicher ich finde alles überraschend also
dass die grünen jetzt so weit gesunken
sind es vielleicht dass weniger
überraschend als der aufstieg der spd
oder der fall der cdu und dem wie gesagt
ich finde die interessanteste zahl ist
immer noch die von einem drittel
offenbar unentschlossenen und die werden
den ausschlag geben das heißt sie haben
dann sind doch auch über olaf scholz
überrascht
ich bin über olaf scholz überrascht und
ich bin aber auch tatsächlich fasziniert
davon dass seine persönlichen
beliebtheitswerte so weit vor denen in
seiner partei liegen es gibt also
offenbar doch viele leute die ihnen ganz
sympathisch finden die sich aber dann
doch nicht dazu durchringen wollen spd
zu wählen und es ist natürlich auch ein
bisschen paradox wenn er jetzt quasi als
erbe des merkel ismus vorgestellt wird
und der cdu-vorsitzende also jene
regierungspartei die 16 jahre an der
macht gewesen ist als der sprung ins
unbekannte gilt das ist eine kleine
ironie dieses wahlkampfs glaube ich also
viele kleine spannende geschichten sind
da noch sind gestern zu tage getreten
und werden auch noch weiterhin uns
beschäftigen und auch hoffentlich die
inhalte wir werden das erleben bis zum
26 september ihnen herzlichen dank herr
leithäuser für ihre einschätzung danke